what is Musk's angle on this afternoon
mark so he's talking about national
security but there's a whole lot of
money riding on this musk testified
about this issue before Congress just a
couple of weeks ago while sitting right
next to his biggest competitor in the
commercial space market United Launch
Alliance chief Michael gas currently ula
a joint venture of Lockheed Martin and
Boeing has a monopoly on the seventy
billion dollar military satellite launch
market because they're the only rocket
maker certified to operate must who
wants very much to break into the
program pointed out ula uses Russian
engines in its Atlas 5 rocket which he
said poses supply and national security
risks especially given the current state
of us-russia relations musk says it
makes no sense to reward Russia with
hundreds of millions of dollars for
rocket engines he called the whole thing
crazy mark so how legitimate are his
comments how over-reliant is the United
States yes so as that self-serving as
his comments may have been his argument
is in fact solid analyst Chris quilty
says you know we won the space race four
decades ago but since we put the first
man on the moon the space program really
hasn't been able to figure out what
purpose it serves in that time the
Russians have overtaken us their engines
power rockets we use to send our cargo
into space and to launch our national
security satellites and we're paying
Russia nearly 71 million dollars per
seat to the International Space Station
analysts say it's important that we not
be at the mercy of any foreign supplier
supplier Russia included and defense
secretary Hagel told a congressional
panel last week that Russia's actions
will lead the Pentagon to review the use
of Russian made engines all that said
though mark the industry still expects
the US Russia space relationship to
remain intact even if the u.s. imposes
sanctions I gotta tell you I my head
snapped up when I heard that figures 71
million per
what what what if Russia did cut off the
supply of rocket engines how would that
affect ula yes so as unlikely as that
would be again 71 million dollars is
hard to turn down and they're probably
going to keep the relationship going
Michael gas CEO of United Launch
Alliance says he has enough rocket
engine stockpiled for at least two years
of launches and that they have the
capacity to build more themselves if
necessary now their spokesperson says it
would take three to five years to
produce the engines in the US and
they're looking at a new American engine
as an alternative but according to one
Raymond James analysts it might not be
possible for ula to produce the engines
fast enough to avoid a gap in the
Rockets availability so you can bet that
SpaceX the only company that can claim
its rockets are completely made here in
the u.s. is hoping it can capitalize on
this moment